So to summarize the scheduling policies, I already
mentioned that first come first serve simply ignores affinity,
and pays attention only to fairness. And these next
two policies that I introduced to you, fixed processor
and last processor, the focus is on cache affinity
of a thread with respect to a particular processor.
That's what we're focusing on. And Fixed Processor was
the last processor. The next two policies, they focus
not only on cache affinity, but also cache
pollution. In particular it asks the question, how polluted
is a cache going to be by the time Ti gets to run on the processor. That's
the question we're asking (no period) In both
minimum intervening, as well as minimum intervening plus queuing,
in terms of making a scheduling decision. And that
should be clear, from the discussion up until now,
the amount of information that the scheduler has to keep. Grows
as you grow, go down this list. The order of arrival is
all that you care about, you put them in priority order
in the queue and you're done with it. And you have, the
schedule has to do a little bit more work, in each
one of these cases, and corresponding with the amount of information that
this schedule has to keep for every one of these scheduling
policies is going to be more. But the result of scheduling decision is
likely to be better when you have more
information to make the scheduling decision. Another way to
think about the scheduling policy is that, the
fixed processor and the last processor is thread-centric in
saying what is the best decision for a
particular thread with respect to it's execution. Where does
this MI and minimum intervening plus queuing? Both of
these are processor-centric, saying that, what thread should a
particular processor choose in order to maximize the chance that the
amount of cache contents is going to be relevant for the
currently scheduled thread? So that's what we're looking at. Now that
I've introduced to you these scheduling policies, it's time for a quiz.